so my talk of the table is an  international celebration that is  finally back after the pandemic  pillow fights yeah you heard me right  pillow fights toronto kicked off the  celebration earlier this month with  dozens of people battling it out now the  fight is typically held during the first  saturday in april but new yorkers since  apparently it's always about us waited  until this weekend to get in on the fun  i just think this is a healthy i love  philadelphia to get out your energy yeah  as an adult there's not too many ways  you can get out maybe yelling in a room  by yourself breaking some plates and  pillow fighting but you know what nate  i'm gonna get hit in the head with a  pillow as i have before that that hurts  hey you got to keep your head on the  swivel sorry i'm like really laughing  too loud that hurts got a  dodge duck dip dive dodge dill  pillows now they're not gonna remember  that they're like all foam  pillow fights definitely knock your  block off